what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday april 26th
the joint is brought to you by zip
recruiter
are you hiring right now let me ask you
something what kind of person are you
looking for
maybe you need someone buddy who wears a
lot of hats finding that person is hard
it's like trying to find a needle
in a haystack or even if you have a
simple position to fill
it could take forever to find a great
fit that's where zip recruiter comes in
you find qualified candidates fast
try ziprecruiter for free right now free
free at ziprecruiter.com slash
joy whether you need to hire a cook in
kalabaskas
an attorney is an arkansas or a mascot
missouri
zip recruiters matching technology hooks
you up with people who have the skills
and experience that you need and then it
actively invites them to apply
for your job in fact zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day
so right now just for my listeners
that's it
you can try zip recruiter for free joey
what are you talking about
you can try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey that's ziprecruiter.com showy try
it for free
i get credit for sending you there once
again you're looking for an employee
listen to me ziprecruiter will find the
best person
available for you try it for free just
by going to ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire
the joint is also brought to you by an
introducing
cbd line they've just come out with a
new hemp flower
and they've come out with a new
melatonin
cbd gummy i have not tried it yet
i will try them tonight and let you know
because
you know me i switch my stuff every
night some night i do to kick them all
some nights i do the melatonin from on
it
tonight i'm gonna try the melatonin cbd
lion
gummies listen when it comes to cbd
cbd lion is [__] making waves
why because they explain it to you they
let you know exactly what's going on
go to cbdlion.com read the third party
lab results and while you're there
register to win a playstation 5. i think
the contest runs till
april 29th registered no purchase
required
and they're still running their 420 sale
i think
which they were giving away up to 35
discounts but listen
whether they are they're not go to cbd
line right now and do me a favor i don't
want you to buy
nothing i want you to read i want you to
read and learn
of what's available to you whether you
have insomnia whether you have aches and
pains
whatever you have cbd lion has a
solution
but it starts by you going to
cbdlion.com
reading comparing and finding what works
for you is it going to be the bath balls
this is going to be smoking it through
your lungs
is it going to be the pills is it going
to be the cbd cream
is it going to be the roll-on is it
going to be the tape this is why it's
important that you go to cbdlion.com
right now
read and if you find something you like
press in joey or church
and get 10 off sent right to your
[__] house
no more buying cbd at a liquor store at
a shoe store
from some [__] guy that can't even
[__] didn't even get his [__] high
school diploma
neither did i but i know my [__]
reefer that's all that matters so do me
a favor
go to cbdline.com right now press in
joey at church
and get 10 to 20 off i don't know what
they're doing every week is different
with them
they just take care if you spend over 75
hours
you get a free gift and don't forget to
register for the playstation 5.
no purchase required pressing joey to
get
your discount now without further ado
let's get this [__] party
started cause it's a monday
and i know you cocksucker's been waiting
for me all goddamn day
candles are lit it's seven o'clock
[__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday april 26th
we're almost out of the [__]
weeds another month
down let's start off by talking about
the
listen i don't like talking about the
ufc because it's rogan's things he's the
master of this [__]
i don't have mma people on here nothing
like that but i do want to talk about
what happened saturday night because it
was a tremendous [__] card
i don't watch all the cards like i
didn't watch the stipe
card i didn't watch that fight i didn't
watch the fight before
i got [__] going on now and i'm a little
busy but this week's card i gotta hand
it to dana white
you know me dawg i talk [__] but that
[__] card was pure heat
and i go what the [__] i was looking
forward to the card all goddamn weak
and i knew i was in a place of bet i
started looking like around tuesday but
i got to make a confession to you guys
today
about how i gamble just so you know it's
this easy
and this is a secret and it's been
winning for me lately
i just don't say nothing about it but
let's start on how i do it first of all
i got introduced to gambling as a child
i enjoyed sports gambling but i hated
paying the [__] bookie
okay big [__] big problem there
you can't [__] gamble and hate paying
the [__] bookies so
i said if it's either between gambling
or snorting coke
both of them are vices which vice am i
gonna go with
i picked behind what was curtain number
two i went with the cocaine because at
least i'm looking out windows and i'm
crawling
and i'm looking and carpeting and i
gotta jerk off and you got dead dick
there's challenges why am i gonna gamble
it's easy
i'm just gonna give some place a bet and
i'm gonna [__] lose because i'm a
loser
i didn't know how to read [__] lines
but then i went to work for a sports
betting service okay and i'm gonna give
you guys a big secret
one of the things of a sports betting
service when they call you and they go
mike how you doing
pete patello here [__] johnny steele
i got a [__] parlay for you that's
going to knock your mother's pep [__]
out of the [__] hair socket
and you're go you're a degenerate
gambler so you're going to fall for
you're going to go a [__] ballet
holy [__] that's that's what i'm looking
for
what's it gonna cost me well it's gonna
cost you 300 to make it three thousand
dollars
ah [__] you john steele i don't know if
i want to [__] do that
you're a phony okay what i did what you
usually do
as a sports betting salesman as you go
okay
fine i'll tell you what you don't want
to [__] sign up with me
[__] uh great have it your way i'm
not gonna sit here and argue with you
over 300
but you know what i'm the type of guy
i'm a christian let me help you out a
little bit
what do you bet and they'll tell you go
go i have jessica andrade
and i have uh uriah fabe uriah hall
okay automatically my response is to say
to them
even though i don't know dick i know
nothing about nothing i don't know about
training camps i don't know about
fighters
my response to [__] with their head is
to automatically say
listen one of your sides is right
but one of yours is opposite well we're
giving out tonight
so you're going to lose you don't tell
him what the team is
you just keep him [__] you just [__]
with that person
and it [__] with their head all night
they're going [__] johnny steele told
me i'm again
when johnny you know what johnny's you
know what your chances are within that
ballet
slim and [__] none so the next day
i'm going to call you as johnny steele
and go johnny steele here didn't i
[__] tell you
you had the wrong side with jessica
andre [__]
jessica android's a great [__]
fighter but you don't know what you know
you don't know which one's gonna show up
last night she had the other monster had
do
you know she showed up with the [__]
martine moreno look
about a year ago and she threw rosemary
maganas on a [__] head
you don't know what she's going to show
up with so there were so many [__]
different great cards to fight last
night so
i looked at the usman against the
george mazdabal fight there was too much
uh
emotion in that fight plus i'm friends
with george this is why when you live in
jersey you don't bet the giants or the
jets because you get emotional
they're your teams you grew up with them
and that's you don't do when i was
growing up it was the nets
and the [__] giants rule number one
my friends would say don't bet them
because you're betting with your heart
not with your head
so i stayed away from the [__] mazda
bar fight
i liked valentina and i liked the other
uh
the other girl the no the other
girl but i didn't i wasn't sure
valentina's a [__] hard hitter but i
didn't know if this girl was gonna pick
her up in body slammer
when she did it against rose i didn't
think it was going to happen
the the anthony johnson against the
australian ac dc came out the highway to
hell i liked it
i didn't know anything about him you
know i know anthony johnson's a killer
so i couldn't just bet that one on a
roll
and i kind of like uriah hall but i like
chris weidman he's a good guy i didn't
want to bet against him so
i was left in a [__] pickle so now
i'm left with [__] thug rose
and yen the girl the chinese girl who i
[__] think is tremendous right so
i'm looking at this thing and i'm going
just so you guys know what i do
so you guys know what i'm doing at night
i'm telling you one of my secrets
the most people don't tell you secrets i
tell you everything here you go
so the only thing i had left was thug
rose and the chinese fight
so i looked at it and thug rose was an
underdog
you got to jump on that all day long
unless you're [__] [__]
unless there's something wrong with you
how can you know doug rose an underdog
you got to jump on that blah it takes
you back to a couple weeks ago
when stipe fought on gayo whatever is
[__] nagayo whatever his name is the
big
african guy not from nigeria from the
other place
but remember he was a thought stipe was
an underdog how many people met stipe
that night
a lot of [__] met steep by that
night i didn't
even know i'm a big steeper male chick
fan because i saw the fix was in he's an
underdog they want you to bet that they
want you to say how can he be a [__]
underdog
so i said [__] i don't want to bet rose
just in case
i think rose could take her but i don't
know but then
thank god the draftkings they have
the over and under on the fights and
they have the boost
so what do i do even with the dirty
screen
i put a when i put those things up at
night
like i love zion williamson i love bet
in new orleans they always cover for me
but i always put when i'm gonna bet new
orleans up
i listen when i bet during the week on
the nba it's 25 bucks guys
i'm not getting rich here i'm just doing
it because i'm having a great time
i'm with draftkings and i get to watch
the game for a quarter
you know it's on mtnt or something like
that i watch the game
while mercy's in the bathtub or
something the game starts at 7 15
and i'll watch it just to see how zeon
is doing but when i put that up on
twitter
and instagram it's not to [__]
promote it
it's to see what you guys say because if
you guys come back to me and go
if i even though i'm let's say let's say
i love
anthony johnson last night right even
though i love anthony johnson i know
he's going to win
i'm going to put it on there and i'm
going to see how many people are going
to go with anthony johnson
if i see too many of you knuckleheads
like anthony johnson
i stay away from anthony johnson because
it's
we you have to go against the [__]
crowd to win
in book making so when you look at
something everybody [__] likes them
like everybody likes them you gotta
[__] be careful so what i'd usually
do at night is when i tweet those things
or i instagram them i do it to see your
reaction
all he has said rose last night not one
of you said when
so i was like [__] now i can't bet
rose
but nunnies made a comment about the
over and under
not one he is looked at it was 4.5 that
means they got to go five [__] rounds
both of them trevor whitman uh trains
[__]
doug rose and what bruce lee's uncle
trains the girl from china
dead both very technical strikers i knew
somebody was gonna get knocked out so
4.5 rounds
that was my best bet of the [__]
night right there that's why i went with
that so when you see i put those things
up at night
for draftkings i'm just trying to get a
reaction out of you [__]
because you'll tell me who to bet
if i see that too many years like new
orleans [__] i'll stay away from new
orleans and sure enough
they'll [__] lose because all of you
guys like them and i'm not saying you
guys are the kids of the debt
i'm just saying that it it's just a
statistic
it's just a statistic to go against the
[__]
whatever like last night once i placed
that bet lee called me
you think i picked up that phone when
leak when i gotta bet it going i don't
pick up the phone with lee why because
he's the kiss of death
my [__] luck will run the [__] out
with lee i know when it comes to
gambling
you don't want to lee around trust me
what i'm telling you you might get hit
in the head with a bolt of [__]
lightning you never know
so when his name came up last night on
the phone before the fight i was like
[__] no
i'm not gonna take a chance by [__]
taking this
this uh thing from lee whatever no i'll
just watch my little
and i gotta tell you something the fight
was [__] tremendous i got up in
between the valentina fight i went
upstairs i made my little michael
jackson tea blend last night my little
fentanyl blend i don't i don't even have
fentanyl i just
i just call it my little happy nunu
blend
i came downstairs i drank it during the
[__] thug rose fight which lasted one
[__] round
i finished in the middle of the [__]
usman whatever
dog when that fight finished and i my
heart goes out to mars but now you guys
know i'm a big fan of his
and i love him to death usman is just
was a little better last night that's it
and it happens
hey listen man what goes up must come
down
you know you can only go up so far and
then
you know and i know this going in and it
happens with comedy it happens with
everything you know what i'm saying
you have a window to [__] do what you
need to do in this life
and you want to make the best of it and
that's it but that's my gambling secret
that i wanted to tell you that's why
i post [__] during the week if i'm going
to gamble at night i test it out on you
guys on twitter you didn't know uncle
joey was a sneaky [__] did you
now to the heart of the matter what
happened last week guys
i didn't see you guys a lot last week
and i'm very sorry
i'm very sorry about 4 20. uh
i woke up tuesday morning to a [__]
missed call from my sister that the lady
who raised me died mrs ronnie rest in
peace
it was [__] 4 20 4 20
or out of all the [__] days but
here's the weirdest thing on everything
that
i moved in with them like
the week that reagan got they
we're trying to assassinate them was the
week of april
21st 1981. it's the
life has a weird way of [__] working
things out man
and then i saw it this [__] week so i
wake up tuesday morning
ready to smoke pot i was gonna break my
own rule and do an edible that [__]
by one o'clock
i had 200 milligrams picked out i was
going to eat them
the whole [__] thing i get the call
at 8 00 40
you know that she passed as soon as i
looked down i was like
[__] i saw who was calling i
answered and they told me she passed and
they were going to do the wake on
thursday and friday and whatnot and i
just sat there for a few minutes
listen guys i wasn't as upset as you
thought i was because i had made my
peace with it i had been expecting it
i felt bad about my brothers and sisters
i felt bad about my brother
they lost a wife and a mom in a year he
had to bury a wife and a mom so that's
what i felt [__] bad about
so i didn't hang up the phone with him i
wasn't off the phone 10 minutes
i went upstairs i had breakfast with my
wife i put my daughter on the [__]
bus i
the whole thing i went in the shower i
got a shower i got another missed call
another friend of mine
his mom was having a hard time going to
the bathroom
and she had stomach pain
and she had to get rushed to the
hospital and this is her baby this is
he's one of my best friends in life and
i heard i could hear his vulnerability
on the phone
i mean he was [__]
in shock like the last person he has
left in his life is his mom
so i could feel it in his voice
how bad he felt the you know he was like
i had to take it to the hospital i
i don't know they found the lump in
their stomach they're gonna do emergency
surgery i don't know what to do i don't
even know where to start
i said wait 10 10 minutes let me [__]
wash my [__] i'll get in the corn i'll
come up
and i'll hang out with you and i'll help
you out whatever the [__] you need he's
my brother what do you want me to do
so i killed like 18 birds and one stone
i got a couple bags of weed like goodie
bags
i flew up there i sat with him i took
him out to lunch while his mom went to
surgery
i made him laugh i made him giggle a
little bit you know i needed to get the
[__] out of here anyway
i went up there i sat with him once uh
he thought his mother was gonna get
taken out of surgery
we went back to the [__] hospital i i
gave him a big hug
i stopped by rose's deli i saw my nephew
nikki a
i saw mikey chick i dropped off a
[__] bone on them
and i [__] uh shot back down here and
uh
you know it was just one of those
[__] days by the time i got home it
was seven o'clock
it took me an hour to [__] you know i
can't see a [__] night
when i drive in fact i'm getting my
glasses i had to go to the optometrist
last week
to get new [__] glasses real glasses
because i use reading glasses
they [__] up my eyes and i [__] use
uh i got no night glasses when i drive
so
i can't [__] drive at night so i
gotta shoot down i was gonna hang out
with
all those guys up there and then
thursday
you know sure enough like i told you
guys i don't want to commit to anything
right now
i do not want to commit this [__] right
now this summer is about my family i
don't want to
tell you i'm going to be there june 21st
and then i get a call that june 21st my
daughter has a softball game and i
cancel
so before i do this i don't want to do
nothing i put some audition on tape
three weeks ago
when do they [__] call tuesday
that's when they call 4 20 in the middle
of this whole [__] thing
they called tuesday to see if i could do
a scene on thursday
oh my god this is what i'm [__]
talking about
i gotta awaken on [__] thursday but
now instead of the [__] wake
i gotta shoot this goddamn thing what do
i tell the [__] family you know what
i'm saying
and they wanted me to do the covert test
even though i had the [__]
vaccine and the whole goddamn thing
so i'm like all right [__] it you know
what i need to do a little work i need
to you know i got this shot what i got
to shoot for they're sitting my [__]
house in fear
so i said [__] it let me go up there
work a day i think i work a day next
week then i work two days at the
beginning of may and i'm out of this
[__] thing
and it's not a bad little movie it's not
a bad little role
so i shot up that [__] thursday nice
and early
uh wednesday night they did the [__]
swab i shot a few hours
and i shot back the [__] down here i was
done it felt great
it felt great to act again two [__]
lines i felt like an [__] but
i did it and then friday morning i gotta
tell you what happened so friday morning
the wake is at nine they're gonna do
like a little mass at 9
30 and then they're going to take it to
the
cemetery and do all that stuff okay i
said i'll go up there for that that's
even better
you know i'll meet them at that veneers
at nine the funeral parlor and then
it's so funny that i grew up in that
funeral parlor like i grew up with that
[__] dude i love him with all my
heart he's like a brother to me
so we're all friends with a guy that
owns a funeral apart that's only like a
[__]
that's a [__] like a tv show like
nobody knows anybody
who embalms people for a living i know
somebody who embalms people for a living
he's never told me what consistently
embalming they got to take a secret when
they get the license and [__] like that
but i have a [__] idea what they do
to you but anyway then
not for the hero there so you know i
live in [__] south jersey all you
hear about is
route 9 is going to be a [__] up
to new york it's a [__] heavy duty
whatever i got up at 6 30 in the morning
i said let me get up early eat some
breakfast with my family see my daughter
before she goes to school
and then i shoot up there i'll be up
there by nine
i'll do the [__] uh funeral the whole
thing
i'll go to the after party with the
family and
uh i'll complete my commitment
i did what i had to do i don't i don't
feel as bad
listen i don't feel as bad about this
because i've been there for 40 years
i've stayed and i kept in touch with him
and i acted like a man like with my
mother how my mother wanted me to act i
did all the things i had to do
i stayed in touch with them over the
years mike visited me in colorado
mike was my best man for the wedding
you know when i came back here in 93 i
actually stayed with mike and his wife
as mike
his wife bailed me out of my [__]
hole helped me out financially with
money
what happens 15 years later their
youngest daughter gets cancer i have an
opportunity to help them out
and i go in full swing i put up the
gofundme the whole [__] thing
we help out you know i move here i get
off the plane i'm not even
off a plane a month his wife died i
could have came up with a thousand
stories i drove to [__] delaware
even though i was [__] petrified or
covered and i had to eat those [__]
little footballs the whole way it was
september 7th
and i was still eating those [__] uh
prasa man whatever the [__] they are
those footballs i must have eaten eight
footballs just to walk into that [__]
funeral but i did because my brother
needed me and that's what a man does
i didn't know this when i was a young
kid i i thought it was all about
something different no
it's about being there i didn't know
this [__] uh
when i got up here they told me they
were gonna have a get-together i showed
up to the get-together i brought my
family
uh when they told me she was sick they
were gonna have a few get-togethers
to go down there i fulfilled all my
obligations
and for the funeral i fulfilled all my
so i didn't feel as bad at all as you
guys might think
i left here nice and early i looked at
the [__] waves thing i gotta take
waves i don't know where the [__] i'm
going waze waves i don't know what the
[__] it is
i pressed that in i pressed in the
[__] address to a different place
because i cut through north i cut to
cliffside park
into north bergen because if you go into
north bergen to route 3
it's [__] traffic got the [__] ass
so i said [__] it
what i'll do is i'll hit it from this
angle but you know what
i got on the thing and i said i would
get
to up by that by 8 12.
i was in [__] shock i go 8 12.
what am i gonna [__] do for 45
[__] minutes
so i in fact i went up my old way i said
[__] i'm not even gonna go through
cliffside
it made me go up to route three right
through i get to see my grandma school
mckinley
i got to see [__] where i used to
walk behind every day i got to see my
old neighborhood
so i said [__] it let me exit kennedy
boulevard hook a left
i'll shoot down i'll go you know what
i'll do
i'll go by my mother's cemetery
say hello i got to the [__] cemetery
the gate was [__]
closed only me so i went the long way
i just went on the corner and i [__]
yelled at her from outside ma
i love you through the [__] gate only
uncle joey could think of that
if you make a [__] left if you make a
right on to whatever the street is
it's carmine balzano's house there's a
little place there where you could pull
over
and i could kind of i can't really see
it with my eyes but i kind of know the
area she's in
so i go ma i love you
you know in spanish some lady was
walking the dogs like what the [__] is
wrong with that guy
i couldn't get into the cemetery the the
top thing was closed and the back gate
was closed
so i [__] hooked down the tunnel
avenue straight up
shot up [__] 64th street 76th street
what's 64th street
76th street i hooked it right down there
and i sailed right into [__] veneries
like i owned the joint
i get there and it's [__] 8 12. i
look around i go there's nobody [__]
here what am i gonna do so i call mike
and they go we're over here eating
breakfast right around the corner so i
went over there
i got to sit with three of the brothers
and the sister joan we ate breakfast we
[__]
i gave them all a little joint for
[__] afterward
because i got a little wrench thrown at
me that day that thursday night i got a
call you ready for this one
i got the screen the soprano flick the
many saints in newark
i'm not gonna tell you anything about it
all i can tell you is i saw it
get the [__] hint you understand me
that's all i can tell you look
i saw it tremendous okay
so those eyebrows are a good thing so
they told me the screening was at 11. so
i go [__]
i can't go to the [__] burial but
that's fine we'll work it out
all that all i need to do is hug my
brother hug them
let them know i was there for them
[__] with them we had breakfast
the whole thing but then there was more
fun to be had
then i went over to veneries because i
we had to be over there at nine so
they're like
are you driving what are you gonna do
i'm driving it's right around the corner
i mean i could have walked over there it
wasn't even
worth the drive but i couldn't leave my
car there on
where i was because they give you
tickets every two [__] hours
ah so i [__]
go up to veneries i i park in but there
is funeral parlor there
and my buddy tommy sharples comes on
he's like hey man
uh you're gonna stay for the funeral go
no i gotta [__]
go into the city but i'll come back at
like two and pick up the [__] car he
goes just turn it around and point it
that way so we know
that you're part of the funeral thing
like all right don't worry i turn around
i walk into venerable funeral parlor
like i said i've known anthony for
[__] 40 years
45 years i've been friends with anthony
we were [__] kids
that funeral parlor i used to work there
as a kid i would open the door for
people we used to pick up bodies
i did everything for them you know what
i'm saying i mean he's my brother how
many times do we go to kennedy airport
to pick up a body newark airport to pick
up a body so i know the
the parameters of the place i know it's
creepy but what do you want to do it is
what it is
when i'm when i was 17 18 i had to do
whatever i needed to do to pick up the
small 40.
you know he paid me 40 bucks to take a
ride to pick up my body 40 50 bucks
you know he'd give me like 35 hours a
funeral i had to open up the door for
people
i'm sorry you know you you don't know
what it's like to open up the door for
people and look at them and go i'm sorry
it's a [__] nightmare but that's what
i did i was just
uh yeah i used to have a nice shirt my
jacket i'm sorry
and they would walk the [__] in so i
walk into the funeral parlor
i don't even i see a bunch of people
mingling i i
look into the office and i see that the
office is completely empty
my buddy anthony i don't know what the
[__] anthony is now
when i was a kid me anthony and another
kid roger
god rest his soul our total relationship
was based on
busting each other's balls so we would
call veneries and the father would go hi
venery's funeral parlor we would go
i wanna rock rock and we would hang up
on him
and anthony would tell him who the [__]
calls up there and says i want to rock
and all this [__] and
you know
[__] like that you know we used to run
over whenever there was a summit
whatever this is a funeral there were a
little uh orange
what do you call those orange things
they put out so you don't run you know
cones they used to be orange cones and
me and roger used to run him over at
night
he used to run him over while he was
standing in front of the thing for a
funeral with the family
standing outside while they're waiting
to put the body into the [__] car
that be little yellow cones orange cones
and me and my buddy roger and stinky
would run
right over him in front of him he would
just close his eyes
and shake his [__] head so we've been
busting his balls
in this funeral capacity for years
so i see that he's not sitting in his
chair nothing bothers him more
than when somebody sits in this chair so
what do i do
i go i sit in this chair and i wait for
him to come back
he comes out with a bagel and coffee
he's like what the [__] is going on i go
dog
sit over there it's different changed
up for once i could tell he wasn't too
[__] happy
but i didn't even think about it you
know i went i went into the parlor i saw
the rest of the running family the
cousins
[__] the grandkids the nieces the
nephews
it was [__] tremendous i saw a little
baby my niece kelly
had a little [__] baby i got to see
her her husband
it was that was the best part about it
then i walked into the [__]
you know where they have the casket and
stuff and there was an open casket old
school
and there was a bunch of pictures and i
looked at the pictures you know and i
was like wow
i put my glasses on i was like this is
[__] crazy
you know they had pictures of me in the
living room and
40 [__] years you know
and i went i knelt down
you know and right away the [__]
comedian in me has to come out you know
i say my little [__] prayer but
i don't know about you guys i don't know
if you've ever been to awake
i don't know if you go to wakes i don't
know if you're a practicing waker
there's people like going awake i don't
like going to wakes
and i'm going to tell you one of the
things that bothers me the most at the
wake
is that you have to go up to the body
and if you're catholic they usually have
a little place where you kneel down
and you're saying our father or hail
mary or whatever the [__] is it that
you're gonna say
you know i'm catholic dog i
i you know i know that pedophiles and
[__] whatever but i gotta
i gotta i i gotta stick to the rules for
right now i'm 58
you guys are 20. you gotta you got
plenty of time to make good with god
i'm 58 i go out any day i gotta stay on
this good side right now so
i can't be talking [__] right now so i
go in
i kneel down i don't know about you
[__]
when i kneel down when you kneel down
you're supposed to put your hands like
like this like praying hands put your
head down and close your eyes listen
whenever i pray i close my eyes but when
i pray
in front of a dead body i always got one
eye open i don't give a [__] if it's my
mother
i don't give a [__] if it's my uncle i
don't give a [__] who it is
i don't give a [__] if it's an enemy or
it's a loved one
i got my eye open looking at that
[__] hand do you understand me
and a dog i can tell you how many
wrinkles they have in their fingers
even without the glasses when i go to a
[__] wake
i'm praying but i'm praying with one eye
closed dog i got one eye on that body in
case that [__] pops up
i gotta jump on that [__] i
watch the walking dead and it's
uncomfortable i don't like none of that
[__]
you know part part of the embalming
thing is
breaking spines and and you know a lot
of [__]
you know embalming and because i heard
about stories like that
arms could pop up like if an arm pops up
yeah bring a mortar sets in you got to
break the [__] arm
and then can you imagine being at a
[__] funeral
and your grandmother's arm pops up and
next thing you know they get they got to
come with a hacksaw
like the guy in snatch when they cut off
benicio del toro's hand you got to cut
off their [__] hand
listen i don't know anything about it i
don't want to see it
when i [__] go to one of those
goddamn things
i keep one eye shut and one eye on that
[__] dead body
because if that [__] squiggles a
little bit you're never going to see me
dog you're gonna see my fat ass i'll run
up against anybody at the olympics bring
the chinese bring the iranians
i'll outrun any of those [__]
when i laid down
i kept my eye open i said my prayer
i thanked her again for taking me in i
told her to say hello to my mother
don't forget to say hello to my mom
she's gonna thank you for taking me in
say hello to rob for me her husband mr
ronnie
and i got up and i [__] uh
hung out with the boys for another 30 40
minutes
we bullshitted just what family does i'm
part of the [__] family man
you know and i uh
got in the car they the guy text me and
said i'm out here
to pick you up to take you into the city
to see the soprano movie
i left my car and i went into the
[__] city and
you know what man i sat there and i
watched that movie
i didn't feel guilty i didn't feel
anything
i enjoyed myself because i did what i
had to do
and i fulfilled my commitment for 40
of being friends with being involved
with the runnies
for 40 [__] years i mean
for a guy like me and for a guy to know
the type of person i am the piece of
[__] that i was
for me to keep in touch with these
people for 40 years for what they did
i look at it as a feather in my cap and
i'm very proud of myself
so with that you know what i'm saying
i mean that was the [__] week i had
but i'm very
very sorry i didn't make a 420 video for
you [__]
you know what i got 800 podcasts go look
at them
there's me smoking dope and all those
[__] and heavy duty [__]
reefer
now what i'm gonna do now right now
listen the other day i cheated on you
[__] i didn't smoke till 222.
that's how bad i'm getting that's how
bad i'm getting i could tell that
i could tell that this uh
you know i just i had to bring down the
numbers guys
i'm smoking reefer that's 35 [__]
percent
i'm smoking reefer that i smoke with
people and i look at them and they're
like [__]
you know and i don't basically get high
so i'm like you know what let's give my
lungs a break
i've been getting a lot of messages
lately of people saying
this pandemic i smoked a lot i realized
that i really started smoking
a quarter a week a half ounce a week i'm
giving it a [__] break there's
nothing else to do it's like people were
drinking alcohol i just got off the
phone with a dear friend of mine
who said he got together with another
dear friend of mine and he goes i don't
know if you've talked to him lately but
his alcohol problem has [__] tripled
and i'm like
doug what did you expect during the
pandemic what did you expect during the
pandemic this was the time
listen man i went off the [__] chains
from april to september
i was part of the [__] problem myself
you know
i told my wife yesterday i'm the kind of
person
don't tell me what to do don't tell me
what to do and i'm gonna tell you why
i'm not telling you it was a
in a threatening way i'm not telling you
there's a bad guy
way it's i don't want you to tell me
what to do
i'm the type of guy i don't want you to
tell me what i have to do
i i want to figure it out on my own i
know what i have to do
let me figure it out on my own when i'm
ready
when i'm good and [__] ready i'll
adjust to it
i don't like when somebody has to tell
me something i've made
my life that's one of my life
goals that not let somebody like i
didn't want somebody to tell me hey bro
it's time for you to leave the comedy
store
look at you got white hair you got
wrinkles on your face
you're a [__] embarrassment you're a
[__] old man get the [__] out of here
not that i'm saying that's the point but
i'm just saying to you
i don't need you know people saying to
me things
i told my wife yesterday you know last
night we were talking
and i go we went out to dinner i didn't
tell you you guys just that watch the
podcast i tell you everything so i'll
tell you this
when i got here with my wife in august
you know i was i was going through
[__] uh
whatever the [__] i was going through if
the anxiety was high level and little by
little it came
down but every time i was around the
public i was really melting the only
thing that kept me together
was eating those 30 milligram hashtags
and the [__]
you know abx and [__] the little
footballs the the [__]
the footballs i i didn't know what else
to do i was falling apart inside i'm not
gonna lie to you guys
and when they went out to dinner me
uh florentine's child my child jim and
his sister and my wife
and the next day at breakfast not with
my daughter there my wife was like hey
man last night at dinner
you were a little [__] up than usual
you were nodding and [__] like that i
know
i gotta i gotta get something together
with my and within one week i put my
plan together on how i was gonna get off
the benzos and how i was gonna get off
edibles and i was gonna switch the
edibles
so i could start going to bed at [__]
11 o'clock at night
you know i did this on my own i i felt
bad that my wife had to say something to
me
but i knew eventually i had to [__]
stop this i had to stop
the way i was living even though i had
insane [__]
anxiety this wasn't gonna work this was
not gonna [__] work
i knew when i came and i got on the
scale and i was 316 that
jesus christ i put on 20 pounds and i
haven't even been here a [__] month
yet
so i knew all the things that had to go
down you know
and you know what look i look a lot
better i feel a lot better i sound a lot
better
when i switch to whatever you know my
daughter walks in the fort
and she walks into the [__]
downstairs
and then when i was having the surgery
you know i was downstairs half the time
she would come downstairs and check on
me you know
my daughter's like i was when i was her
age
i knew what was going on i just didn't
say nothing
you know she's not a stupid kid she
smells that marijuana
she's never physically seen me smoke she
doesn't see any of the pipes
she's never seen a bong nothing
but she does smell it has she ever said
anything to me
no because she knows and she's known
since i lived in california because when
i was
living california my i had a back
bathroom behind my office
that led to the outside so i could open
the door
and go outside and smoke the bong and
lock the door to the bathroom
do you know how many [__] times i
came out of that bathroom and she was
sitting on the computer waiting for me
and i'm fresh i mean yeah i gargled with
listerine i washed my hands
but you could still smell it in your
[__] clothes she's not stupid
but yesterday i smoked in the [__]
house or
was it yesterday maybe saturday or
friday i smoked in the house
she wasn't home it was in the afternoon
she's in school
i went upstairs and when i came down the
stairs
it wasn't like i smelt it downstairs i
smelt it by the front door
and i was like thank god my wife isn't
home because
any day now i'm not going to be up
allowed to smoke in the house
i think this is the last week i think
this is it from now on i'm going to
smoke outside
when i do smoke because this is what you
need to do
this is what needs to be done i don't
want to catch me
you know it's listen if i want to smoke
a joint at night
why don't i roll a joint and just go
down the corner there's a parking
lot there's restaurants there's pizza
places and you go over there and smoke
it's no big deal as a kid
i went for a ride in smoke i don't want
to smoke in my car
i'll go to a destination that's close to
here
smoke a joint and then drive back it's
it's a [__] half a block away
the chances of a cop pulling me over on
me hitting the pedestrian or something
[__] slim and none i mean trust me
it's like
two tenths of a [__] mile to where i
go smoke and if i make a right i got a
spot
and if i make a left i got a spot so
these are what i have to do i don't
i don't want my wife to have to come
tell me and go like dog
she's getting to that age where you
can't [__] spark in the house anymore
but my what i'm getting to is
i gotta be honest with you that's why i
didn't do i was happy in a way
there was listen they all contacted me
for me to do some big 420 thing and
charge you guys
20 bucks and sit here and for a [__]
new york minute i'm not gonna lie to you
guys
i thought about renting uncle vinnie's i
thought about getting jessamy paluso
and lee and mike and going down uncle
vinnie's on tuesday at 4
20 and doing a [__] 10
ticket and smoking dope and introducing
new products and
you know what this is my final
conclusion number one
i would be lying to you because i'm not
johnny 4 20 no more i'm not smoking the
amount of dope
or any amount of edibles to justify this
thing to you
when i put the pictures up on twitter
and [__] whatever
it's to help out my friends over at the
ice cream shop and
they sent me that stuff so i go to sleep
at night but i'm not popping that [__]
in the daytime
look at my eyeballs look at me i'm not
popping that [__] in the daytime
so i'm not captain 420 no more i wish i
was i wish i was and i had the balls
i would have charged us all 20 15 bucks
i would have got jess and may paid mike
paid everybody would have got paid
and we would have smoked some dope or
whatever but that's not who i am anymore
i wish i [__] was i really wish
you got to hydrate [__] but
that's the reason why i didn't do any of
that stuff
you know i'm not the same guy i was i
wish i was
you know i got some [__] training for
years i got some great [__] reefer i
got some great [__] edibles but it's
just not working for me no more so when
it does
i'll be back what type of person would i
be if i went on there and just smoked
the hat for joining uh i'm captain 420
the [__] outta here i was captain 420 at
one time don't get me wrong
i could outsmart all those [__]
you guys know it
and you guys saw it they couldn't deal
with uncle joey but
we all grow up eventually like some guy
last week i want to do a [__]
zoom without smoking who cares go jump
up and down go get your skateboard and
go down the hill
you know what i'm saying and you know
what are you bothering me for
[__] people yeah like what am i ten
with a hat with a propeller i'm an old
man
i'm lucky i'm [__] walking around you
know what i'm saying
but uh that was my week man and this
weekend
listen i'm adjusting
to a normal life i have not had a normal
life
since day one guys my mother was a bar
owner
i saw my stepfather shoot a guy
you know my mother died i i never really
had a family
guys this [__] is all new to me at 58.
i mean what i'm doing on the weekends
now i'm thinking of switching the
podcast to tuesdays and thursdays
because my weekends mike has kids i got
kids
it's not what it used to [__] be i
got a kid
you know and saturdays i'm part of
something
saturdays i mean this saturday we
[__] let you know not gonna believe
last week we're sitting upstairs
and we got the smell in the house we're
like what the [__] is burning so three
nights in a row we could smell [__]
rubber
it was something to do with the god
goddamn generator
so friday we had a [__] when i came
back
or saturday the generator [__] guy
came and he's like yeah there's
something
i got to come back saturday and replace
the [__] thing
so i didn't want mike to come up we were
going to shoot a video and sharing a mic
no
forget it because then thank god the
[__] and i knew it i knew that was gonna
be a bad day when i woke up i knew it
because i heard
the [__] guy down the corner was
cutting a thousand and fifty thousand
[__] trees he had like eighty
thousand [__] mexicans out there
with saws and helicopters and [__]
another guy would i swear to god they
had some thing that was just trimming
off
little [__] trims like uh what do you
call those things that fly in the air
that's right like a drone it was the
weirdest thing what they were doing
i'm like it would have came right
through the [__] microphone
so thank god between them drilling this
[__] guy drilling that was like
enough i had enough [__] drills i had
to make a new hole
for the but you know on saturdays i'm
part of something guys i'm part of
five family traveling
[__] parents and what we do is we
meet
you know each of them have a game we all
meet at one of those games and then we
go and we support the other kids games
and then after that's done we all
[__] pick a place and we go eat
dinner
so last night a saturday night it was
[__] 10 of us and a [__] pizza
parlor
with the kids and the parents i had to
be ten of us 12 of us something like
that it was like five
kids so that's what i'm part of now
i'm sitting there going holy [__]
what the [__] is happening with my life
you know what the [__] are these people
they're talking about [__] that i've
never spoken about before
and all of a sudden i got to catch
myself and go time out
this is what normal people do you'll be
a normal one here you're the one that on
saturdays was in the hotel room getting
ready to do a
a comedy show i mean i told them last
night the table i go guys it's
it's it's 8 30 at night
and right now i'd be getting ready
to [__] go do a comment like right
now i would have to leave you guys like
give my wife a kiss
i would need to be here or i would have
to give my wife a kiss at seven
and kiss her in the baby and go i gotta
leave
you i got to go do a comedy show and i
would miss all this
i don't want to miss this [__] no more
like if i do comedy if i go back to
comedy it's going to be up during the
week it's not going to be on saturdays
because
i can't i don't have [__] time unless
i do it in the winter i don't have
[__] time during the summer i don't
want to miss this
i don't want to miss this i feel bad i
had there was a game on
wednesday night or guys it was the
coldest i was all winter
you understand me it was 47 degrees
with the wind it was like 39. i had
my knee braces on and thank god i wore
them to keep my knees [__] warm
i had knee braces on jeans long sweat
socks
sneakers i had a [__] thermal shirt
a sweatshirt a vest that blue vest i
wear the thermal vest
and a hooded sweatshirt and a blanket
and i was still freezing my [__] ass
off
i felt like i was in san francisco in
september at a [__]
football game me and my wife were
huddled up
and she had her own blanket and i had my
own blanket
she's like we should have brought coffee
go [__] you for what every time we would
have picked up the coffee i would have
froze the deck what am i gonna bring a
[__] coffee thing for
coffee don't do dick in that cold
weather but we sat there and we watched
four innings it's a girls baseball this
week
i mean listen all right the game started
at five and it goes till 6 30. it's like
four innings
by five after six i had to run to the
car and get [__] warm and i had to
pee
i had to [__] pee like a [__]
so i went by the car
i took my dick out i made believe i was
moving bats around and [__]
and i just there was a [__] dog i
peed
it was a circle this [__] big and
then
i peed so it was gonna be like when my
daughter stepped in the car
so i just moved the car up right i moved
the car to the space up so i could watch
my daughter more
and i didn't even move the car up and
some guy moves up behind me some guy
moves in behind me
him and his wife and their kids and they
get out and they stepped in right into
the [__] puddle of piss and i'm like
and the guy's looking around looking at
the piss he knew exactly what it was
he didn't know it was me he couldn't
figure it out so i sat there for like
five minutes just got warmed up
and then i walked back to the field i
sat with my wife
and it was so [__] cold my wife's
like [__] this
i went back there was a handicap spot
right up front
and i pulled the [__] car into the
handicapped spot i said you know what
i don't have a fake sticker or nothing
like that i just paid a 400
ticket it was that [__] cold it was
just gonna be for 15 minutes
if a cop pulls in here now and he wants
to give me a ticket for 15 minutes for
i'll take it like a man i'll suck 10
dicks and pay it but i am not sitting in
those [__] bleachers freezing
there was one grandmother who said [__]
this this is too cold i'm going in the
car
so i sat in there and then when my
daughter got off the [__] bases when
the game ended
we got out we greeted her she didn't
make it she didn't know
and nobody [__] lost their mind but
that's my new life that is my new normal
again on the way home i told my wife
aren't you happy at seven o'clock i
didn't have to nudge you to tell you i
gotta go do a [__]
stupid show somewhere or something so
i'm having a great time
doing what i'm doing right now for me
this is what's working i'm just trying
to get back to normal
i'm trying to live a little bit of a
life so i could have something to write
about
when i go out there and entertain you
[__] suckers like i'm planning on doing
and this was monday april 26th this is
the podcast for today
i'm happy you guys watched it i'm sorry
about 4
20 but hey it was a good week either way
you guys still got stoned you guys had a
great time
and that's all that [__] mattered the
nfts
are coming soon i'll break it down to
you
what we're going to be doing on patreon
and whatever we are with them
we got one of me and lee coming a
commemorative
church of what's happening now [__]
uh nft
so i'll keep you [__] posted
right now at the certain time i got no
dates
all i got is hopes and aspirations i'm
getting better on the guitar
i'm no [__] prince but you know what
that's not what [__] matters i'm not
looking to join a band
i'm not looking to be famous i'm not
looking
to do anything i'm just looking to
strengthen my mind
every time i sit down and play that
[__] thing
you know like this week like last week i
had a bad week playing it
you know the rudy lesson killed me but
me and rudy gonna do another lesson this
week
we were going to do one sunday saturday
at nine but
i again i had to tell him too it's 12.
there's going to be [__] noise the
compressor guy i got my daughter
it's better if we do it during the week
so we're going to do another lesson
and hopefully one of these days we'll
just zoom one and you guys will get to
see it but you got to give me some time
i'm not ready for you guys to call me a
[__] fat jerk off guitar player yet
and all this [__]
so uh with that in mind that's it and
that's that it's a beautiful monday
go out there and do your thing i got
[__] two podcasts this week i got
a lot of escada guy on patreon the
spanish podcast
that comes on monday i got the joey diaz
project
i got a softball game thursday night
with my daughter
i got a game saturday night i got a
[__] uh
kentucky derby party saturday guys we're
living our lives last friday night we
went to a leonard skinner
live at nebwork party at dan
florentine's house i want to thank you
for inviting me it was [__]
tremendous
just trying to laugh my ass off what a
great [__] family
you don't know how lucky i am that they
accepted me my wife and my daughter
my daughter was [__] it was 50
degrees
my daughter went into the jacuzzi the
jacuzzi was 100 degrees
and the pool was 50 and my daughter was
going in and out of the pool like a
[__] savage i looked at my wife i go
what'd i tell you
don't worry about having my wife's like
i don't like her outside when it rains
who gives a [__]
water ain't gonna kill her she's i'm
trying to i'm trying to raise a jersey
girl here
my daughter was jumping into the pool 54
degrees as cold as it was the night
[__] before
put that in your [__] pipe and
smoking so guys
just work with me i'm having a great
time
i'm just getting healthy and when i'm
ready you [__] are gonna know
it
if you thought i was throwing heat
before on stage when i come back
i got a funny feeling i'm gonna [__] you
[__] up for real
i'm gonna make it like my last tour just
to sizzle you [__] that's it
and that's that
i love you guys thank you for watching
the joint
have a great [__] couple days we'll
be back wednesday
with a zoom i know go [__] yourselves
what do you expect
i got i can't be doing this now you
never know you never know what's going
to happen
i love you [__] stay black and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
what's happening you bad [__]
i'm happy uh you enjoyed
my little diatribe today obviously you
don't like the [__] zooms
you want uncle joey to talk to you so
i'll try to talk to you more than ever
now
that i know but before we go real quick
the joint is brought to you by cbd
lion when it comes to cbd cbd line is
the best
how do i know because i tried them all
and i've been working with this company
for years and i reached out to them that
product was so good
they're introducing two new products
maybe three new products
i don't even know what they're doing
they're doing so many good things over
that cbd line
they sent me the cbd hemp flower
it comes in joints and flour and they've
also sent me
the cbd lion melatonin
gummy bears 1500 milligrams of cbd
and 25 milligrams of melatonin are you
[__] kidding me
or not you're gonna sleep like a [__]
baby
if you're looking for cbd cbd line is
the way to go there's not no liquor
store [__] clerk
or some [__] guy from kenya trying to
sell your [__] from
you know go to cbdline.com right now
read read the third party lab results
and read
how learn how they could support
whatever the hell is going on with you
from pain to anxiety to insomnia
cbd line has the answer whether it's
smoking it
rubbing it rolling on it the pills the
bad ball
cbd line has the answer do me a favor go
to cbd lion and when you check out
press in code joey or church and get 20
off delivered to your house it was 10 at
the beginning of the show
[__] it i changed my mind by the end of
the show it's [__] 20.
all right that's how we're doing it
today so go to cbd lion
and tell him uncle joey sanction don't
forget to register for the playstation 5
no purchase required you know how hard
those things are to get
[__] cbd lion has them so once you
order you register
everybody [__] wins go to cbdline.com
right now
pressing joey and get 10 off all right
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my favorite companies ever zip
recruiter why
because they save you time money and
[__] energy
are you hiring right now yeah what kind
of person are you looking for
maybe you need someone to wear a lot of
hats stop right there
zip recruit has got you finding that
person's heart it's like trying to find
a [__] ant in one of those things
you're never going to do it
unless you got a magnifying glass then
you got to melt them anyway
even if you have a simple position to
fill it could take forever to find a
great fit
that's where zip recruiter comes in find
qualified candidates fast try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com
slash showy whether you're looking for a
cooking calabasas
a nurse in nebraska or an attorney in
arkansas
zip recruiters matching technology hooks
you up with people who have the skills
and experience you need which saves you
time
money and [__] energy and headache
remember what
remember the word peace of mind that's
what zip recruiter brings you and then
it actively
invites them to apply for the job get
qualified candidates fast
in fact zip recruit is so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day from an accountant to a zoologist
and everything in between
ziprecruiter makes hiring easier and
right now
today monday just for my listeners you
can try ziprecruiter for free at
zippercoil.com
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com
joey try it for free i get credit for
sending you
and ziprecruiter will help your business
whether you need one employee or ten
zip recruit or bail you out so try it
for free
just by going to ziprecruiter.com again
ziprecruiter.com joey zip recruiter
uh the smartest way to hire i want to
thank you guys again i want to thank zip
recruit i want to thank cbd lion
but most importantly i want to thank you
savages for always supporting the
podcast
on mondays and wednesdays you know who
you are thank you for being here
thank you for giving me the opportunity
and i'll see you [__] wednesday
morning
tip top magoo stay black
and have a great [__] day i love you
so
you